Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Dans quelques jours sort sur
les écrans de cinéma le film Oppenheimer.
On en parle depuis pas mal de temps,
c'est normal, c'est
le dernier film de Christopher Nolan.
Le réalisateur d'Interstellar,
Dunkerque ou Tenet, plus récemment.
Oppenheimer est un biopic sur Julius
Robert Oppenheimer,
le savant qui a mis au point
la bombe atomique.
Alors, on ne va pas refaire le film
dans cette vidéo,
on va plutôt s'arrêter sur son invention.
Comment une telle bombe peut faire autant de victimes et de dégâts ?
Et pour bien mesurer le danger,
on verra ce qui se passerait
si une bombe
comme celle-ci tombait sur Paris.
Brrr... on est en plein été, mais ça fait froid dans le dos.
Le 6 août 1944, les États-Unis font
usage pour la toute première fois
dans l'histoire de l'arme atomique.
Leur cible, une ville japonaise, Hiroshima.
La puissance de cette bombe,
surnommée Little Boy, est estimée à 12 kilotonnes,
l'équivalent de 15 000 tonnes
de TNT ou 22 000 tonnes de dynamite.
But des Américains, contraindre le Japon,
allié de l'Allemagne nazie,
à capituler sans conditions
et mettre un terme aux combats
afin d'épargner des vies humaines.
Mais à l'arrivée, le bilan est effroyable
environ 140 000 morts.
Quant aux survivants, ils souffrent
de brûlures, de lésions internes.
Sans compter les dégâts, invisibles
au départ, mais qui vont entraîner
d'importantes pertes humaines
à cause des radiations liées à l'usage
de la matière fissile.
Trois jours plus tard, le 9 août 1945,
un bombardier largue une deuxième bombe
encore plus puissante sur une autre ville
japonaise, Nagasaki.
Elle fait 80 000 morts.
Pour les Américains,
l'objectif est atteint.
Ces deux événements tragiques
mettent fin à la guerre du Pacifique.
Le 2 septembre 1945, le Japon capitule.
Celui qui a mis au point cette arme
cataclysmique
s'appelle Julius Robert Oppenheimer.
Nous sommes en 1942,
dans le plus grand secret.
Le gouvernement américain
lance un programme de recherche
sur un nouveau type de bombe
la bombe nucléaire,
nom de code Projet Manhattan,
avec à sa tête le physicien américain
Julius Robert Oppenheimer.
L'idée a émergé 3 ans
plus tôt, en août 1939,
lorsqu'un collectif de physiciens,
dont fait partie Albert Einstein, adresse
une lettre au président américain
Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
Ils veulent l'avertir qu'il est
techniquement possible de réaliser
une bombe ultra puissante en utilisant
de grandes quantités d'uranium.
Fervent pacifiste,
Einstein est convaincu
que les scientifiques au service des nazis
vont se servir de cette découverte
pour créer une bombe atomique.
Ce serait un désastre.
Le prix Nobel de physique suggère
donc aux États-Unis d'acquérir des stocks
d'uranium dans le but d'accélérer
la recherche sur la réaction en chaîne.
Roosevelt prend cette alerte très au sérieux.
Il nomme alors Oppenheimer
coordinateur du projet.
C'est l'un des plus grands scientifiques
de son époque.
Il s'est fait remarquer
notamment en démontrant
que l'univers contenait des trous noirs.
Je ne m'étends pas sur ce sujet.
On fera ça dans une prochaine vidéo.
Si le sujet vous intéresse en commentaire.
Durant 3 ans,
Oppenheimer et ses équipes travaillent sur la fission de l'uranium et du plutonium
depuis leur laboratoire
situé à Los Alamos, au Nouveau-Mexique,
et le 16 juillet 1945, la toute première
bombe nucléaire explose dans le désert
d'Alan Gordon
en créant
un nuage de 13 kilomètres de hauteur.
Robert Oppenheimer a réussi sa mission
la bombe atomique est prête.
Albert Einstein, lui,
n'a pas été sollicité pour faire partie
du projet Manhattan.
Il n'avait d'ailleurs
même pas été mis au courant.
Il découvre l'existence de la bombe
atomique en même temps
que le reste du monde, le 6 août 1945,
le jour où elle explose sur Hiroshima.
Il est horrifié.
Peu avant sa mort, en 1955,
il écrit un manifeste pour la paix
réclamant la disparition
des armes atomiques de la surface
de la Terre.
Considérant que ses travaux
ont permis de concevoir de telles armes,
il déclare même à la fin de sa vie
que si sa carrière était à refaire,
il aurait préféré
devenir plombier ou colporteur.
Quant à Robert Oppenheimer,
il exprimera aussi des regrets,
estimant que Hiroshima et Nagasaki
ont été bien plus coûteux en vies
et en souffrance
que ce que voulaient les concepteurs de la
bombe pour arrêter la guerre.
2 bombes
ont suffi pour faire quasi instantanément
220 000 morts et rayer
2 villes japonaises de la carte.
Comment des engins peuvent-ils faire
autant de dégâts et de victimes ?
Qu'est-ce que Oppenheimer et ses équipes ont mis au point ?
La bombe atomique, ou Bomb A, est
aussi appelée bombe à fission nucléaire.
Fission nucléaire.
C'est le nom de la réaction
qui produit cette énergie dévastatrice.
Elle repose sur l'utilisation
non pas d'explosifs
comme dans une bombe classique,
mais de matériaux instables.
De l'uranium pour la bombe qui a explosé sur Hiroshima
et du plutonium
pour celle qui a explosé sur Nagasaki.
Dans les deux cas, le principe est le même.
Ces deux métaux sont constitués d'atomes
des grains de matière invisibles à l'œil
nu, qui se cassent facilement.
On dit qu'ils sont instables.
C'est ça la fission.
Ces atomes sont constitués
d'un noyau composé
lui même de protons en rouge
et de neutrons en vert.
Quand un atome d'uranium ou de plutonium se brise en deux,
il libère de l'énergie et aussi
2 ou 3 neutrons qui à leur tour
peuvent provoquer la fission
d'autres noyaux d'uranium
ou de plutonium.
Pour provoquer une explosion,
comme à Nagasaki ou comme celle qui génère ce genre de champignon atomique,
il faut beaucoup d'atomes.
Et si ça tombait sur Paris ?
Eh bien, je ne donne pas cher de ta peau.
Ce scénario,
très peu probable, a toutefois été imaginé
par des scientifiques.
Tout d'abord,
en moins d'un millionième de seconde,
une boule de feu d'un rayon de 260 mètres
se formerait au dessus de la ville
qui, très rapidement,
prendrait la forme d'un champignon,
le fameux champignon atomique.
À sa base, la chaleur atteindrait
7000 degrés dans un rayon d'un kilomètre.
Tout ce qui vit
et toutes les infrastructures,
les immeubles, les véhicules,
le mobilier urbain, tout serait pulvérisé.
Mais l'explosion serait si puissante
qu'elle engendrerait des pertes humaines
et des dégâts matériels
sur une surface de 32 kilomètres carrés.
La moitié des arrondissements de Paris
seraient touchés.
Ça va, on habite un peu plus loin.
Eh bien, pas vraiment.
Le rayon
d'action d'une bombe atomique
s'étend au delà du rayonnement
thermique et de l'onde de choc
provoquée par l'explosion.
La désintégration de la matière fissile
contenue dans la bombe
génère des radiations
qui se propagent beaucoup plus loin.
Elle provoque des dommages corporels
irrémédiables.
Les rayons pénètrent dans les tissus
et détériorent l'ADN des cellules.
Les victimes, qui au départ
ne se rendent compte de rien,
développent dans les semaines
qui suivent des cancers.
Les personnes qui ont échappé
à l'explosion seraient également exposées
aux rayonnements résiduels
émis par des poussières
ou de la vapeur d'eau
rendue radioactive après l'explosion.
Ces éléments radioactifs peuvent s'élever
à 10 000 mètres de hauteur, voire plus,
sous la forme d'un nuage
qui peut atteindre 400 kilomètres de long.
Ensuite,
elles finissent par retomber au sol.
Tous les organismes vivants, animaux
ou végétaux, qui entrent en contact
avec ces poussières
les ingèrent ou les inhalent
seraient contaminés.
Une fois dans l'organisme,
les particules vont se fixer sur certains tissus ou organes,
comme le foie,
les muscles et le squelette.
À Hiroshima et à Nagasaki,
les bombes ont en fait
causé la mort d'environ 340 000 personnes.
À Paris,
on estime qu'une telle bombe ferait
600 000 morts
et plus d'un million de blessés.
Je l'avais dit, ça fait froid dans le dos.
Et pourtant
ce n'est rien à côté de la bombe H.
La bombe thermonucléaire,
on dit aussi bombe à hydrogène,
a été mise au point
quelques années après La bombe A.
Elle est encore plus redoutable.
Elle dégage encore plus d'énergie.
La plus puissante des bombes
H a été testée
par l'ex-Union soviétique en 1961.
Pas contre des populations,
dans un archipel inhabité
de l'océan Arctique
situé sur son territoire.
Elle avait été baptisée Tsar Bomba.
Cette arme était 4000 fois plus puissante
que l'était la bombe qui a rasé Hiroshima
50 000 kilotonnes contre 12 kilotonnes.
Pour vous faire une idée,
jetez un oeil sur les champignons générés
par ces deux bombes.
A gauche, Little Boy lancé sur Hiroshima.
A droite, Tsar Bomba.
Pour info, les bombes qui équipent
les SNLE français,
les sous marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins font 100 kilotonnes.
Lors du test,
la Tsar Bomba a provoqué un séisme de 5 sur l'ancienne l'échelle de Richter.
On l'a dit, la bombe atomique est l'arme
la plus destructrice
que l'Homme ait jamais inventée.
Mais paradoxalement, c'est aussi celle qui a permis d'éviter
une guerre mondiale depuis plus de 60 ans.
En effet,
peu après la fin de la Seconde Guerre,
en 1945,
le monde se retrouve divisé en deux blocs.
A l'est, les forces du Pacte de Varsovie
dominées par l'Union soviétique.
A l'ouest, les forces de l'OTAN emmenées
par les États-Unis.
Entre les deux, c'est la guerre froide.
Chacun braque ses missiles nucléaires sur le camp
d'en face, mais sans jamais
mettre la menace à exécution.
Celui qui osera larguer sa bombe
en premier le sait il n'échappera pas
en retour au feu nucléaire.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle la dissuasion nucléaire.
Elle est fondée sur une crainte réciproque
des conséquences liées
à l'emploi de l'arme atomique.
On parle aussi d'équilibre par la terreur.
Aujourd'hui, en vertu
d'un traité signé par 180 pays,
seuls la Russie,
la Chine, la France, le Royaume-Uni
et les Etats-Unis sont autorisés
à posséder la bombe atomique.
Enfin, ça, c'est en théorie.
Certains pays ont passé outre le traité
l'Inde, le Pakistan, Israël,
la Corée du Nord et l'Afrique du Sud
qui, depuis, s'en est débarrassé.
De son côté, la France possède environ 250 têtes nucléaires
et 4 sous marins.
Son arsenal est stocké à 90% à l'Île
Longue, en face de Brest.
Chaque sous marin peut embarquer
16 missiles et chaque missile
porte 6 bombes nucléaires.
Chaque bombe affiche
une puissance de 100 kilotonnes.
De quoi détruire une grande ville.
En France, seul
le Président de la République
a le pouvoir
de déclencher le feu nucléaire.
Souhaitons que la dissuasion
reste la règle.
En tout cas, le désarmement n'est pas
pour demain.
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu ?
C'est l'été.
Profitez en chers
Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.
Bonne semaine et à dimanche prochain.